que ha reiterado en repetidas ocasiones
su intención de recuperar crimea un
objetivo que ha aplaudido la Unión
Europea y Estados Unidos Es lógico
pensar entonces que Ucrania pueda estar
detrás de esta explosión
sí efectivamente primero Muchas gracias
por la invitación es un gusto estar aquí
sí efectivamente yo pensaría que es el
caso es muy muy probable igual que lo
que pasó hace un par de meses con
ataques en bases aéreas en Rusia Perdón
en crimea específicamente que pues Rusia
considera como propio no entonces
efectivamente estamos ante una situación
en la cual el gobierno ucraniano tiene
como unos principales objetivos la
recuperación del total del territorio
totalmente Y eso implica crimea Solo que
debido a la tensión que existe y debido
a las amenazas que se habían surgido e
incluso desde el consejo de seguridad de
una forma de Rusia
frente a una posible retaliación nuclear
incluso ante ante agresiones ucranianas
Ucrania nunca se ha tomado la digamos la
vocería nunca o sea se ha otorgado a sí
mismo la responsabilidad por este tipo
de de ataques claro precisamente hacía
referencia a usted a esta amenaza
nuclear y le quiero preguntar
de hecho estas alarmas no que han
reiterado por un lado show biden como
por otro lado el propio pueblo dimirsele
entrevista con la bbc esta amenaza
estaría más cerca ante una posible
ataque a crimea debido que Rusia
considera crimea su propio territorio
sí efectivamente eso es posible pero no
solo eso sino también la situación
política en la cual se está encontrando
que es una situación política muy
inesperada para él donde hay críticas
internas dentro de su gobierno a la
forma como efectivamente se está se está
desarrollando la guerra entonces parece
que hay un sector muy agresivo dentro de
la política rusa que está exigiendo
respuestas y acciones mucho más digamos
concretas y mucho más fuertes ante este
fracaso que se está evidenciando y este
tipo de hechos no hacen sino fortalecer
esa posición Y esa crítica obligando de
alguna forma al gobierno moscúa tomar
decisiones cada vez más fuertes y un
poco cada vez más Temerarios y por
supuesto una posible respuesta elección
nuclear estaría entre esas opciones
entonces usted considera que una posible
uso de armas nucleares vendría por
presiones internas dentro del kremlin no
tanto por una voluntad del presidente
Vladimir Putin
es una combinación
por un lado digamos creo que el discurso
nuclear comienza con Putin con un
mecanismo de disuasión y finalmente como
un esfuerzo por debilitar Y de alguna
forma reducir la presión que Ucrania
está ejerciendo sobre los territorios
que Rusia se han anexado Pero por otro
lado Me parece que dentro de este
círculo interno de de germen aparecen
personas cada vez más digamos no sé si
la palabra sea radicalizadas pero
digamos personas que no que que que
están a favor de una de una de una
escalada de la guerra incluso Más allá
de lo que el presidente ruso podría
estar podría estar mostrando Así que yo
pasaría que sí que efectivamente si hay
una agresión de este tipo sería una
combinación de factores Pero uno de los
principales sería esta presión interna
dentro de Rusia y digamos de del sector
más nacionalista dentro del país